the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
welcome welcome back from Spring Break
today what I want to do is talk about
op-amps and in particular what I want to
do is talk about modularity in circuit
design how do you make circuits that are
modular we'll see that there's special
problems when you think about modularity
applied the circuits and op amps are one
solution for helping us think about
those problems before launching straight
into something new though I'd like to
recap where we are under the assumption
that you may not have been thinking
about this exactly currently so last
time we took our first look at circuits
circuits are very different from the
kinds of things we thought about before
before in programming in linear Systems
Theory we thought about blocks that had
had well-defined inputs and well-defined
outputs
circuits are different circuits are all
connected together and circuit theory is
thinking about how do you organize your
thoughts about complicated interactions
among things if the parts interact
because the voltage because they because
they touch each other and they share
voltages because they touch each other
they share currents and you have to
somehow think about that whole
complicated system we figured out that
the way you think about that can be you
can think about it as three separate
enterprises how do you think about
voltages how do you think about currents
and how do you think about the elements
how do you think about voltages well the
sum of the voltages around any closed
loop is zero nine kvl kirchoff's voltage
law how do you think about currents draw
any surface the net current that leaves
the surface is zero
KCl your house current law how do you
think about the elements well it depends
on the element if you're thinking about
a linear resistor it's Ohm's law V
equals IR if you're thinking about a
source it could be a voltage source then
V
not some fixed number if you're thinking
about a current source then current is
fixed to some some fixed number so it
depends when you're thinking about the
element laws it depends on what element
you are thinking about and then you just
combine all of those and you can solve
the circuit the only problem that arises
is that these equations are highly
redundant there's a lot more KVL
equations than you need there's a lot
more KCl equations that you need than
you need and so in fact the trick in
analyzing a circuit is to figure out the
smallest number of equations that are
adequate the number of equations that
are necessary and sufficient to find a
solution and we went last time last time
we went through three different ways to
do that we thought about what I will
think of as primitive or element
voltages and currents the idea in that
technique is you think about every
element and assign to that element its
voltage and its corresponding current
then that gives you if you've got as in
this example if you've got six elements
that gives you six unknowns one voltage
across every element one current through
every element C then you've got to dig
up six other relationship shows yeah
it's okay sorry start again six elements
six voltages six currents 12 unknowns
you need to come up with twelve
equations six of them are element
equations so six are easy then you have
to come up with six more and for this
particular circuit it turns out that
there is three kv else or three
independent kir costs voltage law
equations and there are three
independent KCl here cops current law
equations twelve equations twelve
unknown salt that's actually more work
than you need to do so we looked at two
other techniques for solving the same
kind of circuit
once called node voltages and another is
called loop currents they are duals of
each other in the node voltage method
you figure out exactly the minimum
number of voltages that I would have to
tell you in order to specify all of the
element voltages so for example if I
told you this voltage here and that
voltage there and this voltage there and
that voltage there four of them that
would let you calculate all of the
element voltages but now I only have
four instead of six four nodes instead
of six element voltages so it's smaller
and we talked about last time how you
could find the correct equations that go
with those nodes node voltages in the in
the loop current method you've specified
the minimum number of currents that
would be sufficient to account for all
of the element current and here in this
circuit it required three three is
smaller than sex there were six element
currents so again we got a reduction in
the number of unknowns twelve four three
so that's kind of the idea and just to
make sure that you're all with it
think about this problem how many of the
following expressions are correct feel
free to talk to your neighbor at the end
of about 45 seconds I'll ask you to
raise your hand with a number of fingers
one through five indicating which is the
correct answer
did the silence you're allowed to talk
okay so how many of the relations are
true everybody raise your hand
indicate the number of fingers that
tells me how many of the answers are
correct come on
blame it on your neighbor if you you
know you can say anything right it's
always your neighbors fault
okay that's very good it's about 95
percent correct almost all correct this
first equation what is this give that a
name
KVL is it correct
sure you need to figure out which path
it corresponds to it goes through and
the only these are over here right so
therefore it must be a something that
has to do with this circuit so this says
that there's 1 2 6 & 5 that's path 1 2 6
& 5 so all you really need to do is
check the polarities so if we took all
of the variables to the same side then
we'd have minus V 1 plus V 2 plus V 6
plus V 5 if we think about going a loop
that goes through the minus V 1 that
would be this way plus V 2 plus 6 plus 5
so that's right easy what's the point of
this equation V 6 equals e1 minus e2
what's that say right I asked that
it's as its intended to make you think
through the relationship between the
primitive variables the element voltages
and the node voltages if I told you the
node voltages e1 and e2 you could
trivially compute v6 you could also
compute any of the other V's right if I
told you to find V what is that my eyes
are not very good v4 if I told you to
find v4 that would be e1 - ground we
assign the number zero to ground so that
would be e1 right
so the idea the reason I asked number
two is to make you think about how you
relate the node voltages to the element
voltages how about number three what's
that well it's highly related to number
two right but it's different from number
two because Ohm's law it's the way so
equation three is the way Ohm's law
looks when you use node equations Ohm's
law is a little bit uglier when you use
node equations then when you use
primitive variables when you use
primitive variables it would have simply
said the same relationship would have
simply said that the six is our six
times I six because I'm using node
voltages instead then the voltage across
resistor six shows up as a difference
how about this one what's that
your boss in this case yeah
sure this is his doctor okay we're
numerous it's not sort of 100%
participation but this is not KCl what
is that
KCl says some of the currents out of
some closed path this is mixed thing
right i6 is one of these things and IB
and IC is one of these things so what is
what is equation for incorrect what
would be the correct way of saying
equation for y just writing why is that
not correct
compression for is intended to be come
here be a complete occurrence to the
element currents the element current so
I six is an element current so the
current that goes through our sakes when
we do loop currents we have two currents
going through our sex so in the loop
current view the total current that goes
through our six is a sum or difference
of the two loop currents that go through
our sex so the element current through
our six which is I sex is a sum or
difference of loop currents there are
two loop currents we have to worry about
which one goes through in the correct
direction I six goes from left to right
so when we do the loop currents we need
to take positive as the direction from
left to right well that's the direction
of IC and it's opposite direction of IB
so if I want to use loop currents to
specify I six it would be IC minus IB
everybody clear on that so equation four
is the relation between element currents
and loop car keys so what's equation
five equation five is Ohm's law for our
six I would have V V 6 equals i6r six
that's the way you've said in element
voltages and currents over here the
current through R six is IC minus I B so
Ohm's law looks a little bit more
complicated so the point is these three
methods represent ways of figuring out a
linearly independent set of unknowns and
equations they differ the left-hand one
is probably the easiest to think about
especially when you're thinking about
things like Ohm's law
it's the natural way to specify the
element relationships
it's the relation between the voltage
and current through that part that gives
me a large that generally gives me a
large number of equations and unknowns
you can reduce the number of unknowns by
using something like no voltages or loop
currents and that gives you fewer
equations to solve they are completely
equivalent they look a little different
and the reason for talking about them is
that when we think about writing a
program to solve circuits automatically
which by the way will be the exercise in
software lab this week when we think
about writing a program writing a
program is yet a different kind of
challenge what's the easiest system to
automate so the system that is easiest
for you may or may not be the easiest
system to automate so that's the point
of this this week software lab will
write would do a method that's closely
related to the node voltage method it's
not quite no voltages it's a little
simpler than node voltages for a
computer it's a little simpler to
automate so we use a method that's
called node voltages with component
currents okay
okay now I'm going to start a new stuff
that was review what I want to think
about today is what is it about circuit
design that makes it hard how whatever
the issues that make it difficult to be
modular when we're thinking about the
analysis and design of circuits and one
of the hardest things to deal with is
the idea that in a circuit unlike in a
linear time-invariant system of the type
we talked about in the previous module
in a circuit the presence of every
element affects the currents and
voltages through in principle every
other element so if you change
one thing you change everything so first
off I want to just give an example of
that
think about what would happen if I was
trying if I were trying to make a
circuit to control the brightness of a
light bulb so imagine that I've got this
circuit and I close the switch closing
the switch is equivalent to adding a
component so before I close the switch
when a switch was open I have three
elements voltage source and two
resistors after I close the switch I
have four elements the original three
plus of the ball so the question is how
would closing the switch effect V naught
and I naught take a minute talk to your
neighbor figure out how V naught and I
naught change
so what's the answer everybody raise
your hand show number of fingers equal
to the answer that's very good it's 95%
correct at least maybe a hundred okay so
the answer is two why is the answer to
how do I figure that out so the idea was
that when you add a component let's
think about the light bulb being a
resistor okay that's kind of a food out
of thin air but I sort of suggested that
you might do that here think about
representing the light bulb as a
resistor then when you close the switch
these two resistors go in parallel when
you combine two things in parallel the
result is the same as a resistance that
has a smaller value and then think about
how that smaller value would interact
with this resistor and that source and
you can sort of figure out that the
presence of this bulb would reduce this
voltage and increase that current that's
kind of a high level of reasoning given
where we are if you wanted to think
through this a little more step-by-step
it's easy you can think about figuring
out what are the voltages and currents
before and after you close the switch
before you close the switch you can just
ignore this and you can calculate V not
just from a voltage divider relationship
right that's clear so you can see that
when the switch is open the voltage is
going to V naught is going to be 8 volts
and when the switch is open you can
figure out the I naught by lumping these
two resistors together to make a 3 ohm
resistor and you see that I got is 4
amps
then to figure out what happens when you
close the switch just repeat and the
algebra is a little more tedious I won't
try to go through it by the way the
answers the slides that I show in
lecture are always posted on the web so
these slides that have the answers they
are their selves on the web there are
two handouts for lecture there's a
electronic version of the thing that we
handed out there's also an electronic
version of my slides so everything that
I showed is there I'm not going to go
through the tedious algebra it's just
tedious algebra but if you go through
the tedious algebra you find that if you
represent this ball by a resistor R v
naught becomes an expression that looks
like this if you think about resistors
physical resistors if you think about
lightbulbs being represented by a
physical resistor then the physical
resistor has to have a resistance
between 0 and infinity and if you think
about that expression
what could the value be if are varied
between zero and infinity that
expression is always less than or equal
to eight volts showing that V nought
went down when you closed the switch
similar tedious algebra leads to an
expression like this in R and if you
think about how this would change as R
goes from zero to infinity you see that
that's always bigger than four amps so
that means I naught goes up so the point
is you can think through this in a more
sophisticated way and we hope by the end
of the course you all be able to do that
or you can think through it in terms of
just solving the circuit solve it in two
cases when the when the bulb is there
and when the bulb is not either way the
answer is to that V nought went down and
I naught went off the point is that when
I added the element currents that were
far away from the element still changed
and that's a general way circuits
interact they're all connected so the
idea the point of doing this is that the
addition of a new element changed the
voltages and currents through the other
elements
and that's a drag if what I was trying
to do for example was design a
brightness controller for the flesh
light bulb imagine that what I really
wanted to do was use a voltage divider
to make a Volks and what was in my head
was I'd like that eight volts to be
across the light bulb that's a good idea
it just won't work at least it won't
work the way this circuit worked if I
just build it like so there's an
interaction between the bulb and the
voltage divider circuit so the voltage
divider circuit is no longer a voltage
divider after I've in this circuit when
I close the switch current flows in this
wire the rule in a voltage divider is
the same current has to flow through
both resistors if the same current flows
through two resistors and you can use
the voltage divider relationship to see
how voltage partitions between the two
resistors if current gets siphoned off
the node between the two resistors you
can't use the voltage divider relation
anymore that violates the premise of the
voltage divider relation so when I close
the switch this is no longer a voltage
divider and it no longer works like a
voltage divider is that clear so what
I'd really like is some magic circuit
that I can put here that isolates the
effect of the bulb on the effect of the
rest of the circuit and that's exactly
whether or not vamp does that's what
we're going to talk about next
so this magic circuit is something that
we'll call a buffer a buffer is a thing
that isolates the left from the right so
the buffer is going to be something that
measures the voltage on this side and
magically generates that voltage over
here without changing this side so what
we want to do now is develop some
thought tools for how you think about op
amps op amps are different and if you
just look at the picture op amp has to
be different because there's too many
terminals okay it's not like a resistor
that has two legs it's not like a V
source which has two legs it's not like
an eye source which has two legs it's
three legs in fact I haven't drawn all
the legs
there's more than three there's at least
five so they're different and the way we
think about them are different the key
to thinking about the way an op-amp
works is to think about a new class of
elements called controlled elements so a
controlled element is an element whose
voltage current relationship depends
somehow on a voltage and current
measured someplace else in a circuit as
an example think about a current
controlled current source that's
depicted here the current that this
current source I would normally generate
I would normally write a current source
or as a circle that means it's an
independent current source that means
that the current is fixed the little
diamond thing is my way of representing
the idea that the the amount of current
that comes out of this current source
depends on something else in this case
it depends on IB and IB happens to be a
current that flows in that circuit so
the idea is that the current in the
current source depends on some other
current it's a current controlled
current source it's a current source
whose current is controlled by another
current got it
so we'll see figure out for this current
controlled current source circuit what's
the ratio of V out over v yet
so what's the answer what's the ratio of
V out over V n question to be easy I
rigged it to be easy because you can
sort of figure out everything that's
going on the left and then you can
figure out everything that's going on
the right and so it's there's no sort of
complicated coupling between the two so
what's going on on the left well you can
solve for IB IB is just VI over a
thousand ohms then you can take that
value of IB and use that to solve for
what's going on over here over here the
out is this current a hundred IB times
this resistance five ohms but we just
found out that IB is VI over a thousand
ohms substituted in you get half VI so
the answer is number four the ratio of
the out to VN is a half so the point is
these are a different kind of element
controlled sources dependent sources but
they're not too hard to work with
they sort of look different structurally
so think about what's going on here the
controlled current source the current
controlled current source I have to
think of that as a box because the
current source has to know the value of
IB so somehow this box this thing that's
doing this current controlled current
source it knows about IB and it knows
about the current source so there's
somehow linked so that's why I put a box
around it and then think about the
equations that characterize that
component so now we got a component
that's got four wires coming out of it
the components we had before had two
wires coming out of them
resistors current sources voltage
sources this kind of a component has
four wires coming out of them we call
this kind of a component a two-port
because we think of the left part and
the right part
that's compared to a resistor which we
would call one port so we think about
this being a two port and there's now
two equations so now we have now I've
got for that two-port I've got two
voltages and two currents
there's the voltage across the left part
and there's the voltage across the right
part and there's the currents through
the left part and there's the current
through the right part so with with the
elements we've thought about before I
had one voltage across it and one
current through it now I've got two
voltages across it and two currents kind
of twice as big not surprisingly it
takes twice as many equations Ohm's law
was a single equation for one resistor a
one point V equals V naught was one
equation for one component a voltage
source here I've got one component that
has four wires
four unknowns and I get two equations so
for this particular dependent source I
know that the voltage across this pair
of terminals is zero because it's
essentially a short circuit between the
two short circuit just means connected
with a wire and I know that the current
i2 is related to the current over there
this way so the idea then is that this
current controlled current source can be
represented by a two port two voltages
two currents related by two equations
it's kind of structurally twice as
difficult to think about as
all-important functionally it's
different from having two one ports
because the two one ports are coupled
and that's the important part is the
coupling between the two that you can't
model with a simple resistor and a
simple constant source okay so when we
think about an op amp a good first model
for an op amp is to think about it as a
voltage controlled voltage source and so
that's depicted
here I want to think about the op-amp
which I'll symbolically write this way
this means something that has two inputs
a plus input in there minus input and a
single output V out I can think about it
as a voltage control voltage source so
this I mean to be the element
representation this is how I'll draw it
when I make a schematic diagram of a
circuit this is the functional form this
is the way I'll think about it when I'm
analyzing it I'll think about the op amp
as being a controlled as a voltage
controlled voltage source this voltage
source adopts a voltage that is some
number K times the difference voltage v+
minus v-
and the trick in op amps is that k is
typically a very big number typically
bigger than 10 to the fifth we'll see in
a minute why that's a frightfully useful
way to think about a frightfully useful
component so let's just walk through an
example to see how you would solve a
circuit that has this kind of a voltage
controlled voltage source in it so think
about this circuit where I'm applying a
voltage to the plus lead of an op amp
and I'm wrapping the output back through
the minus lead through two resistors and
what I want to do is analyze that
circuit by thinking about the op amp as
a voltage controlled voltage source so I
can see just by the way that's wired up
that the voltage at the plus lead so I'm
going to be thinking node voltages no
voltages tend to be easy I'm thinking no
voltages so I'm going to define all my
voltages reference to a ground so I'll
call this node ground that's what the
funny symbol means then this node
voltage the voltage at the plus terminal
is just the same as the input voltage
this voltage at the minus terminal looks
like a voltage divider relationship if
you look at my model it's very clear
that I 1 is 0 because there's no
connection
year between the V Plus and the V minus
so I one is zero that means the total
current that flows into the Plus lead of
the op-amp is zero the total current
that flows into the - lead of the op-amp
is zero so because there's no current
flowing in the plus and minus leads I
can calculate the voltage at this minus
terminal as a voltage divider and it's
just R 1 over the sum of R 1 and R 2
times V 9 then according to the voltage
control voltage source model V out
should be K times the difference between
the the V+ and V - so I just substitute
him for V Plus this guy v ma VI + 4 V
minus this guy do some algebra I get
this expression after some algebra and
then I say yeah but I know that K is
really big so if K is really big K R 1
is big compared to R 1 so I can ignore
that in fact K is so big that for any
reasonable choice of R 1 and R 2 K R 1
is even bigger than R 2 so that means
this reduces to this kind of a fraction
so the response of this circuit this
op-amp circuit so what did i do I just
took the op-amp circuit and I modeled it
as a voltage controlled voltage source
plugged through the equations and found
out that the ratio of the output voltage
to the input voltages are 1 over r1 plus
r2 divided by r1 so the idea then is
that this simple circuit works like an
amplifier
it's an amplifier in the sense that I
can make the output voltage bigger than
the input voltage that's a very useful
thing in fact you'll find useful ways to
use that when you do the design lab this
week so this is an amplifier so here's a
question make sure you follow what I
just did
how could I choose the components r1 and
r2 so that I make V out equals VI
there's no wire connecting so there's
nowhere for current to go
okay so how would I choose the
components r1 and r2 in order to make
the output voltage equal to the input
voltage wonderful so the idea is that
all of these manipulations have the same
effect all you need to do is look at the
expression that we developed the
expression was r1 plus r2 over r1 if you
substitute our 1 goes to infinity RZ 2
equals zero or the two at the same time
you get one in all of those cases so
that's a way that you can turn this
amplifier circuit that in general would
make the output bigger than the input
into something that makes the output
equal to the input okay now I want to
turn to a simplification I just dragged
you through the math thinking about the
op-amp as a voltage controlled voltage
source there's actually a shortcut the
shortcut is something we call the ideal
op-amp so what I want to do in this
slide is drag you through the math one
more time but then we're done the idea
is that if you have an ideal op-amp if
you have an op-amp a voltage controlled
voltage source if you represent an
op-amp as a voltage controlled voltage
source and if K is very big the effect
will be to make the difference between
the positive and negative terminals of
the op-amp quite small you can see that
here by way of a simple example so let
me think about this case with again the
voltage controlled voltage source model
so here I've got V out according to the
voltage source the voltage controlled
voltage source model V out should be K
times the difference between the two
inputs the positive input is clearly VI
the negative input is vo one equation
two unknowns solve for the ratio the
ratio of V out to VI is K over
Plus cane that's the answer take that
answer and back substitute to figure out
how big was the difference between v+ +
v - that's just algebra and what you see
is that if this is the answer then the +
- v - can be written as a fraction of VI
or a similar fraction of VO k is big k
is essentially the same as k plus 1 k's
in the denominator of both what that
says is the difference between the plus
and the minus leads the voltage between
the plus and the minus leads is very
small if K is very large ok that's a so
we call that the ideal op-amp
relationship the utility of that is that
it makes solving the op-amp circuits
much much easier than what we've just
been doing I've been solving the
circuits by thinking about the op-amp as
a voltage controlled voltage source
that's fine but if i additionally know
the K is very big I can sure cut it I
can say look the effect of the op amps
going to be to make the positive and
negative inputs the same if it didn't do
that think of what it would mean if K is
a big number and if the output voltage
is K times the difference if the
difference is anything other than
epsilon V out has to be infinity
I mean if K is very big right if K is
very big the only way the output could
be some reasonable number like a volt
would be if the difference between V+
and V - is very small ok well let's meet
let's work backwards let's start with
the assumption that V Plus is v+ minus
v- is very small and that lets us solve
the circuits very quickly so for example
the same circuit that took previously a
few lines to get the answer to if I just
take as a rule that V Plus has to be V -
it's a one-step V plus equals V -
okay VI equals vo period done it's a
very simple way to think about the
answer to an op-amp circuit so if the op
amp can be represented by a voltage
controlled voltage source and if K is
very large then V Plus is roughly V
minus shortcut ideal op-amp assumption
so use that or ignore it depending on
how what your mood is and figure out the
voltage relationship for this slightly
more complicated circuit
so what's the answer yes no how many are
done how many are not done okay
take a minute this is most be easy think
ideal op-amp
okay what's the output everybody raise
your hand what's the output more hands
we're hands we're hands / hands okay
tiny number of hands but those who
showed hands are about 100 percent
correct I don't have a grade bag right
a small participation 100 percent among
those who did participate so how do I
think about this with step 1 what was
the previous slide
- what happens here if he + is equal to
V - well what's V + towards V minus zero
so if V minus is zero
what do I do now which three different
currents can flow how big is the current
that can come into this node what's the
sum of all the currents that can come
into that node well one could come in
this way one could come in that way one
could come in that way how much current
flows in the - lead of the op-amp none
no current goes into the - no current
enters the op-amp through the - lead so
it's the sum of three currents how big
is this current how big is the current
that flows in that lead v1 v1 over one
right Ohm's law so this node is zero
that node is v1 the voltage across this
resistor is v1 minus zero the voltage
across is v1 the current is V 1 over R R
is 1 so the current that flows in this
leg is v1 how much current flows in this
leg how much current flows in this leg V
nought so the idea is that the total
current that flows into this node is v1
plus v2 plus V naught so for V naught V
naught is minus v1 minus v2 right got it
so the idea was that this is really easy
to solve if you use the ideal op-amp
approximation you can see that this is
zero therefore this is zero so you have
a single KCl equation and the result is
that this circuit looks like an
inverting summer it computes the sum of
v1 and v2 and then takes the negative of
that and presents that at the output so
what I'm trying to motivate is that
there's a whole different level of
reasoning that you can do when you have
this element which is an op-amp here
what we've done is we've made something
that performs a numerical operation it
presents at the output the negative sum
of the two inputs
okay another problem determine R so the
V nought is twice v1 minus v2
so how should I choose ours not very
many hands this is perfect
Nana quiz practice right this looks like
a perfect Nana quick question right
smile so I hate so what's the answer
okay we're down to about half correct
this is harder basically you do exactly
the same thing it's just that it's a
little algebraically Messier so not
surprisingly the first idea is the thing
about the ideal op-amp so we'll think
about what was the voltage here what was
the voltage there and then we'll equate
them so what's the voltage at the plus
lead well that's easy that's just a
voltage divider here so since no current
flows in here I can compute the voltage
relative to this ground as R over 1 plus
R that's showed here times R times v1
this one's a little bit trickier because
I've got two sources V 2 and V naught
each pumping current into this place the
way I thought about it was start with v2
and then add to it this component which
can be thought of as a voltage divider
here so how big is the voltage at minus
that V - well it's v2 plus a voltage
divider here which is given by this
that's a little tricky if you're not
comfortable with that step you could
also solve for that voltage using the
node method the node method will give
you the same answer the answer is that
the voltage at the v- port is 2/3 of v2
and one third of V nought it sort of
looks right because the resistors are in
a ratio of 2 to 1 and then using the
ideal op-amp assumption we equate the
two do some more algebra and we get some
relationship and figure out that R is 2
the point is that this is a relatively
complicated circuit you could have done
it if I had asked you to do it with the
voltage controlled voltage source model
but the algebra is already hard here
with the ideal op-amp assumption and
with the voltage controlled voltage
source it's even harder so the idea is
that the ideal op-amp assumption the
idea that V Plus is equal to V minus
makes the work of calculating these
responses significantly easier okay
everybody's with the bottom line okay so
we started with the idea that when you
add an element to a circuit in general
adding an element changes voltages and
currents throughout the circuit we
wanted a way to make the design more
modular a way of adding a component
without changing everything else we
thought about this op-amp thing the the
model for the op-amp was voltage
controlled voltage source we inferred
this ideal op-amp model the ideal op-amp
model is great for calculating the
response it has this one problem it
seems to say these circuits are
identical if I literally believe the
ideal op-amp assumption that all the
op-amp does is magically make the plus
and minus terminals the same I would
conclude that this circuit where the
input comes in the plus and the output
wraps around to the minus generates the
precisely the same input-output
relationship as this one where the input
comes in the minus and the output wraps
around the plus the ideal op-amp
assumption simply says for both of those
VI a was vo so I would assume from the
from the ideal op-amp model I get the
result that these two circuits Genet
works
actually the same way somehow that
sounds wrong I got this part and I can
wire it up the right way and it works or
I can flip the two wires and it still
works I mean the conservation of badness
doesn't let that happen right if you do
something bad it should break so I've
got so the ideal op-amp assumption seems
to lead to a bogus result it seems to
say these two are the same so what I'd
like to do is think about that for a
moment we want to be comfortable with
the assumption that we make the ideal
op-amp assumption makes analysis really
easy but we'd like to understand exactly
what we're assuming this just doesn't
sound right okay so let's back up let's
not do the ideal op-amp assumption let's
instead say that we use the voltage
controlled voltage source model so what
I've done here is substituted into the
left circuit so this circuit is shown
here and the other over here all I've
done is connected the input either to
the plus or to the minus pour it and
wrap the other one around but now I'm
analyzing it using the voltage
controlled voltage source model and I've
done the tedious algebra and I don't
think there's any mistakes in the
tedious algebra in one case I get K over
1 plus K which for large K is about 1 in
the other case I get minus K or what -
okay which for K large is about 1 ok so
the ideal op-amp assumption says that
doesn't matter the voltage controlled
voltage source model says it doesn't
matter and Freeman thinks this doesn't
make any sense ok so what's going on
here what's going on is that we've
actually made an enormous leap in
thinking about the op-amp even as a
voltage controlled voltage source the
two models that we talked about the
voltage controlled voltage source and
the ideal op-amp model are great for
calculating answers they are not so good
at providing a mechanism for how the
op-amps actually working think about
just the ideal op-amp assumption it's
great to think okay the op-amp is going
to do whatever magic is necessary to
make these two leaves the same okay well
how does it do that the thing about the
ideal op-amp assumption is that it
doesn't tell you the mechanism by which
that happens
what's the op-amp actually do in order
to get V Plus equal to V - what's
actually going on inside the op-amp the
ideal op-amp assumption is very good for
analysis and not very good with
mechanism what's the mechanism
what's the op-amp actually doing what's
the op-amp actually doing what it's
really doing is moving charge around
8:02
charge so if you're gonna have a change
in voltage there has to be motion of
charge and that's what's missing from
the voltage control voltage model and
from the ideal op-amp model how do you
think about moving charge around well
it's the same as moving water around
somehow I find I think it's all those
years of playing with water when I was a
little kid I find my intuition about
water is better than my intuition about
charge so let me start by thinking about
the intuition for water the way a water
tank works is if the flow in is
different from the flow out the height
changes right that's continuity so if
the water is conserved if there's not
significant evaporation over the
duration of this experiment or if
molecules of water do not spontaneously
disappear or appear under either of
those two assumptions then the change in
height is proportional to the difference
between the rate at which is coming in
and the rate at which is carrying out if
the rate of which is going out is equal
to the rate at which is going in there's
no change in height if it's coming in
faster it's going out if it's coming in
slower it's going down okay
Oh easy right charge works the same way
the thing that accumulates charge in
electronic circuit is a capacitor and
there's a direct analogy between
thinking about the way water the flux of
water generates height and the way flux
of charge generates volts so we can
think about the flux of charge that's
current if there's a net flux if the
difference if there's if there's a
bigger current into a capacitor then
there is out the voltage on that
capacitor goes up if there's a smaller
current in then goes out the voltage on
the capacitor goes down just like the
height in a tank of water we can make a
much more realistic model for the way an
op-amp works by explicitly making a
representation for how the charge flows
and that's showed here I'm going to take
the voltage control voltage source model
but explicitly make a representation for
the output charging up what's the op-amp
do the op-amp senses the voltage at the
input and the output and does something
to change the voltage at the output the
thing it does is if the voltage at the
positive voltage is more is greater than
the negative voltage it pumps charge
into the output node if the opposite
occurs it sucks charge out now it's
importantly this is not an act an
accurate depiction of what's inside an
op-amp this is the model for an op-amp
okay I don't want to lead any of you to
think that this is literally what's in
an op-amp this is not literally what's
in an op-amp here is much more literally
what's in an op-amp this is the
schematic diagram of a 709 which is a
widlar circuit it's a complicated
transistor circuit it's ingenious
this is how you build a circuit that has
the remarkable property
the ideal op-amp circuit it's not
perfectly obvious from here and even
here this doesn't give wiggler enough
credit here's what he really did he
designed masks to shield semiconductor
materials so that you could turn them
into transistors so that it would turn
into an op-amp okay we're not going to
worry about this right this is two
levels of abstraction more complex than
we're gonna worry about we're just gonna
say okay I don't know what's in there
but this is the way it behaves this is
intended to be a behavioral model for
how an op-amp works and in fact that's
an important idea that we use circuits I
use circuits on a daily basis not
because I design semiconductor devices
but because I work on biological issues
I actually study hearing and we make
circuit models for the way biological
parts work and that helps us to
understand the way the biological part
works so for example here is a model
taken from 602 one where we try to
understand how a nerve propagates an
action potential by making a circuit
model that's the same thing we're doing
here we're making a circuit model for
how the op-amp works it's not a literal
it's not intended to be literally what's
inside the op-amp is intended to be a
model that lets us think about the
behavior of the op-amp this lets us
understand now why it's different
when you flip the wires let's start with
the original configuration where I put
the voltage in the puff sleeve and I
wrap the output back around to the minus
lead what's going to happen what's the
outbound actually do imagine that things
had been stable this was zero the output
was zero everybody was happy and now all
of a sudden the input voltage just steps
up what happens
okay the input voltage steps up the
voltage source suddenly generates a huge
positive voltage and that starts to put
current into the capacitor that
represents the
at the output of the op-amp so as a
result of this voltage being higher than
where it was current is being dumped by
the op-amp into this capacitor and the
output voltage starts to increase that's
shown in red as the capacitor voltage
gets bigger as the output voltage
increases the difference between V+ and
V - gets smaller and the charge the rate
at which charge is flowing into the
capacitor slows and in fact as the
voltage at the output gets very close to
the voltage at the implant the rate of
current into the capacitor goes to zero
and the output voltage stabilizes at the
input voltage the same thing happens
when you reverse if I were to change the
input voltage and make it go negative if
the input voltage went negative then K
times V plus minus V minus would be a
big negative number and it would suck
current out the voltage control voltage
source would suck current out of the
capacitor and make the voltage fall the
voltage would follow the absolute
difference between the plus and a minus
before it would get smaller the current
flowing would become less and it would
again stabilize at the width when the
output is equal to the input contrast
that to what would happen if I put the
input into the - port if I put the input
into the minus port and the input goes
through a step then the input going
positive makes the voltage controlled
voltage source generate a big negative
voltage it sucks current out so the
input went positive and the output goes
negative it goes the wrong way that's
bad okay so here if I put the input into
the minus leave
a positive transition of the input leads
to the output going the wrong way and as
it goes the wrong way the drive to make
it go the wrong way gets bigger it's a
runaway system it's positive feedback so
the the idea is that by squirting the
input into the negative lead instead of
into the positive lead leads to a
positive feedback situation in which a
small change at the input makes the
output go the wrong way convinces the
op-amp that things are getting worse so
it makes even more current which makes
it go even more the wrong way and the
same thing happens with the flipped
situation so the idea then is that by
thinking about the flow of current
what's the op-amp actually doing the
op-amp is actually sensing the
difference between the voltage at the
positive port in the - port and it's
sourcing current that changes the output
voltage to go up or down you need to
wire the op-amp so that ultimately the
output equals the input otherwise the
ideal op-amp condition that V plus
equals V minus will never be attained so
the left one is what we would refer to
as a stable feedback situation you can
think about that it's analogous to
thinking about a ball in a value so we
have a valley and we have a ball the
ball is gonna roll down here eventually
it's stable Bop it a little bit to the
right it'll roll back into the valley
Bop it a little to the left it'll roll
back into the valley that's as opposed
to when we've wired up the wrong way
it's like we have an unstable
equilibrium we it's as though we're
trying to put the ball there BOP it a
little to the right it runs away to the
right BOP it a little bit of left it
runs away to the left that's unstable
there is a medicine if you actually
balanced it exactly exactly exactly at
the right place it would stay there
that's what the solution is telling you
that was the minus K over 1 minus K the
fact that the equations had a solution
is correct it's just an unstable
solution the tiniest little disturbance
will make it go awry
so the idea then is that it the ideal
op-amp assumption is fine it's a good
thing to use it doesn't tell you about
the mechanism if you think a little bit
more about the way the physics works you
have to wire the circuit up so that it
has negative feedback in order to get a
stable equilibrium so if you understand
that and you just make sure that you've
hooked it up so that it has negative
feedback then you can use the ideal
op-amp assumption everything's just fine
and in the interest of time I'm gonna
just skip over this because we've
already talked about all of this it's
just another example the last thing I
want to mention is just that in order to
work this magic the op-amp has to get
power from somewhere and the way and so
that means that it's not a three
terminal device it's not the kind of
device I've been drawing so far there's
got power pins too and the way the
op-amp works is it takes power from
those power pins to be able to force the
output to a voltage that'll make the
input the V Plus equal to V minus that's
the mechanism by which it works and
that'll have important consequences when
we build the robot head because what it
means is that we're not going to be able
to generate arbitrary voltages at the
output of an op-amp we're going to be
limited to generating voltages that are
between the power rails
so if we were to supply plus or minus 10
volts to the power pins we would not be
expecting to be able to generate 20
volts at the output so that's an
important implication when we do the
design lab so in summary what we've done
is we've showed how circuits can be a
pain to make modular because in
principle adding 1 components changes
voltages and currents everywhere but
there's a way using op amps to have this
furring idea that lets us logically
separate parts of circuits so that one
can control the other have a good day